hello everyone welcome to the biggest
ideas in the universe i'm your host sean
carroll
and today we're finally getting to an
idea which i think many of you have
probably been hoping for
for a long time certainly long time fans
followers of stuff that i like to talk
about
will know that i was going to get here
eventually we're talking about entropy
today in fact
entropy and information information
turns out to be closely related to
entropy
but related to it in a kind of subtle
and confusing way so it's worth talking
about in its own right
now entropy is something we've already
mentioned we mentioned it in the episode
on the nature of time
because as we'll talk about today we'll
fill in some gaps back in the time
episode we talked about how the fact
that entropy increases
is responsible for the arrow of time for
the fact that the past and the future
are so different in our everyday lives
so we'll be able to fill in some of the
gaps
here but we also talked about entropy
just in the last video when we talked
about probability
and randomness because the way that
entropy comes into
the history of physics in the 19th
century uh
involves this appreciation that we don't
know everything about the universe we
have to talk about probabilities for
things
and people realize that was at the heart
of how we should be talking about
entropy
so we even gave the formula for entropy
in uh the
in in the sort of boltzma one of one of
boltzmann's various ways of uh writing
down entropy
this is the reason why entropy is hard
uh not the only reason but a reason why
entropy is hard is because
there are many different definitions of
it and none of them is wrong
right all these definitions serve a
purpose they apply to a different set of
circumstances
entropy was uh it's funny because
entropy is
plays a role in the second law of
thermodynamics right which can be
roughly stated
that entropy increases but doesn't
decrease in closed systems
but the second law was invented by saji
carnot
before the word entropy was ever
invented so he formulated
without the word entropy the word
entropy was suggested by clausius
who reformulated the second law in terms
of entropy but he didn't really have a
definition for it or rather
he had a definition for it in the
macroscopic world of thermodynamics
but the microscopic definition in terms
of atoms and molecules wasn't there
so finally the definition came along
with boltzmann and others and it turns
out there's more than one
definition that's what makes it
complicated anyway
here's how we're going to think about
entropy for today entropy is a way of
characterizing our ignorance about the
system
that's what we talked about last time in
the fact that probability comes into
the clockwork newtonian laws of physics
by saying well
but we are not laplace's demon we don't
know the positions and velocities of
everything so there's some things we
don't know
how can we nevertheless do physics and
make progress
so entropy is a way of thinking about
given how much we do know
so we do know some things right we know
the temperature the energy the total
number of particles
in a system or something like that some
observable
macroscopic features entropy tells us
how much we
don't know how much the macroscopic
information
leaves out from the ultimate microscopic
specification of the state
so it's a measure of our ignorance in
some way and just
saying that just saying those words you
should already be suspicious okay
because um entropy is supposed to play
a role in the second law of
thermodynamics um
that's a very important law in physics
people like arthur eddington famously
said you know you can
you could violate charge conservation or
conservation of energy or whatever but
if you violate the second law of
dynamics then your theory is obviously
wrong
so it's a very beloved law but if in
this way of stating what entropy is
it makes it sound you know personal and
subjective
like how much i don't know compared to
somebody else
you know what about an alien or a robot
could they no more would the entropy be
different for them
and this is part of one of the reasons
um this is one of the reasons why
the concept of entropy has been so
contentious over the years
uh we're not really going to get into
that very deeply but i want to let you
know that was one of the
issues it turns out you know here's what
it turns out i mean
in the in the spirit of not uh keeping
surprises to the end
um yes there is this idea when we talk
about entropy that there's something we
know and something we don't
but that's not arbitrary right it's not
like well some people know something
some people know other things there's no
way of reconciling what's going on
we have ways of observing systems we
observe a cup of coffee
we can see you know what its temperature
is where the cream is where the coffee
is stuff like that okay
what we choose to be macroscopically
observable
is not arbitrary it is something that we
have access to
given the laws of physics there are no
robots that look at cups of coffee and
see all of the atoms there isn't enough
information coming out in the photons
from
all the atoms there might be robots that
see more than we do
okay and that's fair and that's
something to keep in mind
but it's not completely up for grabs
it's not completely random roughly
speaking
any alien or any human being or any
other animal sees the same sort of size
and shape and temperature for something
and those determine how much we can
include how much we can infer about the
microscopic state
and that's what the entropy is telling
us okay
so let's get into some more specific
notions i'm going to contrast i think
i'm going to define entropy four
different times over the course of this
video
so first let's give two different
definitions of entropy both of which
live
in the context of classical statistical
mechanics okay so we're thinking
we're in the 1870s now we we've become
convinced that atoms are what matter is
made out of
and we're thinking about the statistics
of these atoms okay so classical
mechanics lives in phase space
as we talked about last time so you have
the set of positions x i
and momenta pi okay
and what one way of thinking about
entropy and this is
you know i know a lot about the history
but not nearly enough the history is
fascinating of this stuff
i'm going to give you the definition
that is engraved on ludwig boltzmann's
tombstone in vienna
okay but apparently number one um
it wasn't he never wrote that down he
never wrote down the definition of
entropy that is engraved on his
tombstone
and number two it wasn't even originally
part of the tombstone i i'm informed
that it was sort of put on there later
and uh
max planck more than anyone else was
responsible for that
way of writing down the entropy but
nevertheless we call it boltzmann's
definition
he certainly had ideas like this in mind
and the idea is
to coarse grain this is the important
move we're going to make here
and what that means is you say look
there are
many many particles in a macroscopic
system i don't
see every single particle position and
velocity
but there are some things i do see and
so given what i do
see maybe the size the temperature
things like that the microscopically
observable features
given that there are probably many
different microscopic arrangements of
atoms and molecules that would look that
way
right and so i coarse grain by saying
i'm going to include
all of the different microscopic
arrangements all the different points of
phase space
i'm going to call them a single macro
state if they look
observationally the same to our
macroscopic point of view
so basically coarse graining is saying
uh
if microstates so let me let me say it
this way
macro states are what we will call
sets of microstates
and a microstate is just a point in
phase space because a point in phase
space tells you exactly
what's going on in the system so
microstates are set of points in phase
space
that look the same i'll put look the
same in quotes
because then you can go home and argue
with your loved ones about what that
means to look the same
it might be dependent on what you're
able to look at but once you've decided
what you can look at
the coarse graining is well defined so
the picture that we have is something
like this
let me draw it this way kind of looks
like a bullseye
so this is phase space okay the space of
all possible
microscopic states of the system
microscopic in this sense by the way
doesn't mean small
it just means exact it just means
complete it means i'm giving you all of
the information if i give you the
microstate of the system the position
and velocity of every single
particle in that system and so the phase
space here
is coarse grained into macro states so
these
regions of phase space are the macro
states
okay so i basically arrange them so some
of them are small
some of them are big et cetera it's a
fascinating question to talk about what
is the right way
to core screen what is the right way to
divide up into macro states what are the
properties that you naturally get
i think this is actually an area where
there's a lot we don't know or a lot of
work that has not yet
been done a lot of a lot of things are
assumed to be true
even though we haven't really
investigated them carefully yet let's
let's put it that way
okay so now we can pick out let's let's
pick out this
macro state right here okay the
microstate is the whole region because
the microstate is a set
of microstates and then boltzmann says
look that region
in the entire phase space that region
has a volume
okay and basically he says the entropy
what we'll call the boltzmann entropy
even though he had other definitions
s equals k log
w where w equals the volume
of that macro state that we're pointing
at
so in other words there's a volume in
phase space
there's an integral that we could do to
figure out how many states are in that
macro state
and this is a very nice once once you
define the macro states
this is a nice definition because it's
very it's very precise like once i pick
out
a point if i knew what the microstate
was
i could still assign an entropy to it
under this definition
right so this entropy is not subjective
in the sense that
once we agree on what the observables
are and therefore what the macro states
are
everyone agrees on what the entropy is
okay it's not directly about your
knowledge
again once you agree on what the macro
states are
this is something which for every
microstate you can just say well what
macro state is it in
let me count the volume of that macro
state that's w
i take the logarithm of that multiplied
by boltzmann's constant
k equals this constant of nature called
boltzmann's constant
and then i get the entropy
so the log we talked a little bit about
logarithms
last time remember the logarithm is an
operation mathematically that undoes
exponentiation
so the log of e to the x
equals x and e to the log x
also equals x so e to the x
is the inverse of the logarithm of x in
in some way
and we can plot that you should have
done this last time sorry about that
this is log x versus x
so if you think about it when x equals
one
okay what is the logarithm of it going
to be
well uh actually this is that's not good
yeah
so what is the number that we
that we have to raise e to think about
this definition
okay what is the number you have to
raise e to to get one
well e to the zero is one so
any number to the zeroth power gives you
one so the log of one
better be zero and then the logarithm
function goes like this it'll never hit
zero itself but it sort of grows forever
but it grows ever more
slowly in fact famously in physics
logarithms appear all the time
in physics but a logarithm is a slowly
growing function it's even slower than
linear
once you get to be an expert physicist
if you if you listen to uh the podcast i
did with scott aronson
there's a lot of discussion about the
growth rate of different functions
because he's a computational complexity
theorist and that's how you count how
hard it is to solve a problem in a
computation how many steps it takes
and in particular how many steps the
computation takes as a function of the
size of the input
does it go as the log of the size of the
input does it go linearly quadratically
exponentially and all these are caring
about how fast the function grows
asymptotically okay as you go towards
very very large values
so logarithms grow very slowly now why
why do you want to count the entropy to
be the logarithm of this
short version is remember the idea of
entropy was already there
okay it preceded the idea of kinetic uh
kinetic theory as we call it the idea
that atoms are what make up gases and so
forth or statistical mechanics
as the modern version would call it and
so we already had to map on to that
pre-existing definition
and the feature was that if you have two
systems and bring them together
the entropy of the total is supposed to
be just the adding up the entropy of one
plus the entropy of the other but if you
have two systems made of atoms
and you bring them together and let the
atoms cross over into each other the
phase space grows a lot
because now there's a lot more room for
all those atoms to move so
it turns out that the phase space grows
exponentially when you bring the two
systems together and therefore if you
take the log
and define the entropy to be the
logarithm of the volume rather than the
volume itself
you maintain that feature that the
entropy of the combination is the sum
of the two entropies and it also it has
other nice features but that is
historically why uh boltzmann invented
it
okay so this is a nice thing uh
because like i said if you give me the
microstate i can specify exactly what
the entropy is
it it's subjective to the extent that
you need to pick out your coarse grain
you need to pick out what counts as a
macro state but once you do that
you're done let me contrast that with a
very different way of thinking about
entropy not a very different way but a
different way
and this is usually called the gibbs uh
entropy josiah willard gibbs as an
american chemist and physicist
and it's actually closer to the
definition we used last time and it's
very close to definitions that boltzmann
and maxwell also use so
all these people were talking to each
other at the time but at the end of the
day you need a label okay so when i call
this
the boltzmann entropy don't think that
this is the only thing that boltzmann
thought about i'm just
labeling this particular definition s
equals k low w
because it's on his tombstone all right
that's as good a reason as anything
uh and here is the gibbs entropy which
comes from
you know philosophically a very
different place the boltzmann entropy
comes from coarse graining
so even before you tell me what the
system is you tell me what i can observe
about the system and use that to chunk
up
phase base into macro states the gibbs
entropy says forget about coarse
graining
it doesn't use coarse graining at all it
just says there's something i know about
the system and something i don't
and what the way that that knowledge is
conveyed is
in the probability distribution so we
had to do probability first in the last
video
so that we can now talk about the
probability so
let's imagine that we have a probability
distribution
on phase space and i'm going to simplify
my life a little bit
by just using x to denote the the point
in phase space rather than just writing
x and p every time because last time
when we talked about the maxwell
boltzmann distribution we cared about
the difference between x and p
now we just care about where we are in
phase space so we're not even going to
distinguish between x and p so i'm just
going to use the single letter
x to be a point in phase space so we
have a probability
distribution on face space and i'm going
to call that
p of x so x is now a point
in face space that's just notation not
not doing anything sneaky or or physical
there just simplifying
my uh what things are gonna look like on
the page
and then the entropy mapping on it's
close but not exactly the same as what
we talked about in the last video
is minus the integral of p of x
times the logarithm of p of x
over all dx okay so this would be the
gibbs definition of entropy although
like i said boltzmann and maxwell and
others also used it
and uh there's probably a k here
right from now on boltzmann's constants
from now on i'm setting k equal one as i
promised in the last
video um but i think that there's
usually going to be a k there
so this is a particular thing this is a
number the entropy that we don't attach
to microstates
okay so in the boltzmann way of doing
things we could take a microstate ask
what macrostate is it in
and therefore say okay that's the
entropy of that particular configuration
this philosophy the philosophy of this
approach
is very much related to how much we
claim to know about the system the
probability distribution
of being in different places in phase
space
so it's absolutely tied to how much we
know
if you know exactly the microstate okay
if your probability distribution
function is what we call a delta
function it's
one or it's actually infinitely big at
one point in phase space and it's zero
everywhere else
then you can you can figure out that the
entropy according to this formula
is uh zero it's zero entropy state
there's nothing you don't know
this is telling you how much you don't
know
about the system so let's uh let's let's
do an example let's show that uh
in a simple one-dimensional example
it becomes difficult to draw the
pictures in more than one dimension so
here's all of phase space which i'm
going to write as x
and here's a different probability
distribution p of x
okay so a high entropy
probability distribution is one where
you don't know that much
which is a way of saying you give a lot
of probability to different possible
points in phase space so maybe something
like this
would be a high entropy
and you can actually you know go home
and calculate you know
just take a constant for example plug it
into that formula figure out what the
entropy is
and then you could contrast it with a
formula that looked like this okay and
there is a constraint the integral of p
of x itself
has to equal one remember that was one
of kolmogorov's axioms that if you sum
up all the probabilities for all the
different possibilities
you better get one so the two curves
have that normalization
you know their total area under them has
to be equal to one but you
what you're asking is are they
concentrated in some region
and very very small elsewhere or are
they spread out all over the place
the ones that are concentrated are low
entropy
so low entropy really means
i'm pretty likely to have the system be
in a certain region right you know
sort of this region right here is
probably where the system is if i'm in
that low entropy state
uh whereas high entropy says i don't
know i have really no idea where the
system is
so you can see already that there
becomes a relationship between
entropy and information in this way of
thinking about it the higher the entropy
the less information you have about the
system the low entropy system you know
something about it
and just to make you happy that we're
not just completely making things up
this is compatible with boltzmann
compatible
in the following sense uh if you
know that your system is in
some certain macro state so if you have
phase space and you have coarse grained
it and you know what macro state it's in
but you don't know anything else okay
then you can say well i give a uniform
probability distribution
to being everywhere in that macro state
and zero
everywhere else then the two formulas
are going to coincide
so if i have in this one dimensional
example if i have let's say here are my
coarse grained macro states okay
unless i'm in this macro state right
here then if i put a uniform probability
distribution
here's p of x and i normalize it so the
integral is 1 etc and i calculate this
then s equals log
w is also going to equal log of p
the integral of p log p dx
there's a minus sign there okay so
they're compatible in that sense this
particular kind
of uniform p of x
uniform in one macro state uh gives you
the same entropy either way
but operationally they're different okay
they play a slightly different role they
evolve in
different ways the boltzmann entropy and
the gibbs enter being
so let me give you an example of that so
the second law of thermodynamics
which is where we're trying to get to
here second law of thermodynamics
says uh that the entropy of a closed
system
either increases or remains the same
over time
for a closed system
so um you've heard this before right
i'm sure that we've heard that statement
before now that we've given you two
different definitions of entropy let's
think about whether or not you would
expect
this sentence to be true uh well
for the gibbs entropy you don't expect
it to be true
in fact it's false well it's not it's
not false for the gibbs entropy you get
a much much
stronger constraint which is that s
remains constant
for closed systems because the entropy
according to gibbs
is literally a way of measuring how much
you know about the microstate of the
system
but even though you're not laplace's
demon you don't know the exact
microstate you have some probability
distribution
it turns out that you can use the
equations of motion
to evolve the probability distribution
at one time to a different probability
distribution and
if the system is truly closed
then for the gibbs entropy
you can just write d s dt the the change
in the entropy with respect to time
is just zero for a closed system
so i mean that's a true statement but
it's not the second law of
thermodynamics
uh so what is going on um
it's because you're not sorry let me
explain why this is true it's just a
statement that you're not forgetting
anything about the system right if
entropy goes up
according to the gibbs definition of
entropy then what you mean is that you
know less and less
about the system but in principle if you
knew what it was doing in the past and
you know laws of physics you know the
same amount now
that you did then so it's not surprising
that the entropy doesn't change in the
gibbs formulation
what you can do however is modify your
situation a little bit remember in the
last video we talked a little bit about
being handed a box of gas by a
mysterious stranger that was completely
isolated
and we said you know for many purposes
it's actually easier
more physically illuminating to imagine
being handed a box of gas that is
coupled to a heat bath okay so if you
have a heat bath
so if your box of gas is embedded
in some world that has a temperature and
can
slowly very very gradually exchange
energy
between the inside of the box with the
gas and the outside at some temperature
t
then you get a new rule with the gibbs
entropy
okay the gibbs entropy this this
equation about how much you don't know
if you think about it
if you started by knowing a lot in a low
entropy state
inside the box okay but now it's being
jostled
by all the air molecules in the heat
bath or by the outside world more
generally even though
molecules don't come and go information
momentum and energy
can come and go and you don't know
what's going on there
you can't keep track of all the exchange
of information and heat and so forth
with the heat bath and therefore
entropy can go up sadly
entropy can also go down in this
situation if you think about it
um you know this is sorry about the
siren out there
philosophically this is saying how much
you don't know but you
know something which even in this heat
bath case you know something which is
the temperature
right and the temperature is relevant if
you remember the formula for the maxwell
boltzmann distribution the temperature
came into
the actual probability distribution that
you reach in equilibrium
and it's not surprising to think that
when the temperature is
higher there's more room for the
molecules to be doing all sorts of
things
so given a box of gas with a fixed
number of particles inside if you
increase the temperature the entropy
will go up
if you decrease the temperature the
entropy this gibbs entropy will go down
the molecules will settle down into a
smaller region of phase space
as they get colder if you take a bottle
of champagne that is warm and you put it
in a refrigerator
its entropy will go down okay so
we are still looking for a correct way
of stating the gibbs entropy
and we're still in this video scientists
know how to do this what is the correct
way of stating the second law
in this case the answer is that there is
a law that says that the change of
entropy
is greater than or equal to the heat
that is exchanged
with the outside world so if the system
and the heat bath it's embedded in
are essentially at the same temperature
then you will get the second law of
thermodynamics then the entropy will
just go up
but you have to if you want real
physically applicable laws
let the entropy of systems go down when
they're not closed
systems okay this is this is not a rule
that is supposed to be true for closed
systems this is a rule that's supposed
to be true
if you're coupled to a heat path but
philosophically you know morally it's
still the second law
at work uh it's just letting you letting
you
be in a more general situation where he
can be exchanged
so that's the the slightly subtle
situation of the second law in the gibbs
formulation
um what i should have said i should have
said this uh let me say it now
if you contrast this gibbs formulation
with the boltzmann formulation you know
given that
the second law is not quite as obvious
in the gibbs form you might say well
therefore i think the boltzmann form is
better
which is fine the problem is that if you
actually want to
study the evolution of a system over
time that is not a
closed system that is open most systems
in the world do interact with the rest
of the world after all
it's much easier to solve the equations
in
the gibbs formulation event in the gibbs
formulation of entropy and it is in the
boltzmann formulation if you think about
it
this probability distribution can change
gradually over time and the entropy can
gradually increase
whereas in the boltzmann formulation as
you move
from one macro state to the other the
entropy suddenly jumps up or jumps down
and so that's harder to keep track of
numerically you don't know if you're in
the boltzmann formulation if you're in
some macro state are you near the
boundary of that macro state you know
when is the entropy going to go up
it's just harder to deal with
numerically so we actually end up using
formulas like the gibbs formulation much
more often in
uh real uh fluid dynamics or statistical
mechanics calculations
but the boltzmann formulation gives you
actually a much
cleaner idea why there is something
called the second law of thermodynamics
and why you'd be tempted to
write about the second law foreclosed
systems
for closed systems why well it's kind of
obvious right okay why
the second law
the idea is if you start with this kind
of coarse-grained
structure in phase phase okay phase
space
and you start the system at a low
entropy state
and just let it go let it evolve however
it wants to evolve
uh it's going to wander off from a low
entropy
macrostate to a high entropy macrostate
for the simple reason that there's a lot
more volume
in the high entropy macrostates there
are a lot more ways for the system to be
high entropy than to be low entropy
in fact this figure does not come
anywhere close to doing justice to the
real world in the real world
the high entropy macrostates are
enormously larger
than the low entropy ones so this looks
like well yeah probably you moved a
higher entropy but maybe not
but in the real world the probability in
the system with many many particles the
probability for moving
to higher entropy states is
overwhelmingly large
um if you start with if you start in a
low entropy state
now but nevertheless even though that
sounds pretty
straightforward and convincing and
probably in the modern 21st century way
of looking at things you're not bothered
by that
in the 19th century they were bothered
by this they thought
that the second law of thermodynamics
was a law
they many many people let's put it that
way it was an independent law
so the project of maxwell and boltzmann
and gibbs and all those people was to
reconcile
the clockwork classical mechanical world
of newton and laplace
with this uh time-ordered probabilistic
world
of randomness and statistical mechanics
and so what boltzmann argued was that we
should think about the second law of
thermodynamics as something that is
almost always going to happen not even
almost always in the mathematical
true sense is overwhelmingly likely that
entropy is going to increase in a closed
system and you can quantify exactly how
likely it is um but people didn't like
that they're like no no it's a law
it's a law like the conservation of
energy is a law you don't say that
energy is usually conserved you say it's
conserved full stop
okay so they were bothered by
boltzmann's formulation of it and they
tried to
argue with him so let me talk about some
of the arguments because they're
actually you know
people are still arguing we know the
second law is true we know that atoms
exist
but exactly the right way to formulate
these laws and to think about them is
still
a little bit contentious so let's
mention a couple of the objections
uh low schmidt
low schmidt was a professor who's
actually one of boltzmann's teachers so
he was one of baltimore investors he was
he was on
boltzmann's side like they were friends
they talked with each other
but he didn't really like boltzmann's
formulation the second law at first he
came up with what is called the
reversibility
objection
it's a pretty simple thing it's one of
those things where you know right place
at the right time you can get your name
on something that is actually pretty
simple
and he said look if you think about this
picture
okay let's just draw redraw the picture
in a slightly
smaller way okay here's a smaller
version of the picture
the underlying theory the microscopic
theory
is newtonian classical mechanics and a
feature of newtonian classical mechanics
is time reversibility
there is no arrow of time in newtonian
mechanics
for every trajectory going one way there
is another trajectory going the other
way in time
all you have to do is take momentum and
go to minus momentum typically
okay so for every trajectory
in phase space with
ds dt greater than zero
there's one you can reverse it that's
why it's called the reversibility
objection
there's one with ds dt
less than zero so in particular if you
say well i start here and i go out in
various ways depending on where i start
from
there's an equal number of trajectories
like an exactly equal number
that go from high entropy to low entropy
so
in the space of all trajectories in the
space of all things the system could be
doing
there it is equally likely that you
would find the system
increasing in entropy or decreasing
entropy and
that's not wrong he didn't make a
mistake low schmidt um
and boltzmann you know argued against it
and and it's funny so i did
when i wrote a book about entropy in the
arrow of time called from eternity to
here you're welcome to buy the book and
read
many of these historical details um
boltzmann responded in various ways and
the funny thing was you know boltzmann
was always convinced that he was right
but the reason why he thought he was
right changed with time even within a
single paper he would offer different uh
responses to this
and so the but we now have settled on
more or less what the right response
is and the right response is there is a
symmetry
in newtonian mechanics between going one
way in time and going another way in
time that's time reversibility
so the coarse graining does not break
that symmetry nor does the dynamics we
need something else to break the
symmetry if you want to claim
to have an explanation for the arrow of
time boltzmann thought he was just
deriving the fact that entropy had to go
up
and that's not true he did not derive
that because
low schmidt was right entropy could go
down in the space of all trajectories
what you need is a boundary condition
you need an initial condition for the
universe
you need to break the symmetry the time
reversal symmetry
with a boundary condition
and this is one of the ideas that
boltzmann
put forward he said you know he
called it you know proposition a or
something like that the idea that
at some time in the past the universe
started in a very low entropy state
that's it it's just an extra assumption
it's not derivable from anything we've
said
so far so david albert has labeled this
the past hypothesis
david albert was one of the guests on
the mindscape podcast we talked about
quantum mechanics but
one of his most influential works was a
book called time and chance where he
really laid out
the logic of this situation you need to
be able to say
that the universe began
i'm putting began in quotes and i'll
explain why in a low entropy state
so by that simple stroke of the pen you
simply eliminate
all of these bad trajectories that are
decreasing in entropy you just say that
you start here
and if you start there then indeed you
do are you are very likely to increase
in entropy
okay why do you have to say begin in
quotes because
really what you need to make it work is
that at some point in the history of the
universe
not too long ago the entropy was much
lower than it is today
and by not too long ago we mean much
shorter than the equilibration time
for the universe the time it would take
to go from low entropy to high entropy
and indeed this is true empirically uh
when we look at the universe
the past near the big bang 14 billion
years ago
had a very low entropy and
so this is indeed true
near the big bang
and in fact you know one thing that you
could wonder a good question for
historians of science or for science
fiction writers is
why didn't boltzmann invent the big bang
theory
uh you know we're talking about circa
you know he was
confronted with the reversibility
objections in the 1870s
you know he poo-pooed them they moved on
and then but he revisited the problem
for various reasons in the 1890s
it was really in the 1890s that he wrote
his most in-depth explorations of this
question
and he never quite you know he did he
did suggest that the universe had
some kind of condition at early times
you know
but he never said well that would be the
beginning of the universe
and you have to imagine in the 1870s we
didn't know about general relativity we
didn't know about expanding space
or the expansion of the universe or
anything like that we didn't know about
singularities
so it would have been extremely bold for
boltzmann to say well maybe there was a
first moment in time in the history of
the universe but it wouldn't have been
crazy and it's not impossible to imagine
he could have said it look you look on
the sky
and stars are shining okay
boltzmann better than anyone else knows
that that can't go
on forever because the stars shining
increases the entropy of the universe
and they
will eventually use up their fuel and
stop
shining so the idea that the universe we
observe today
could exist forever in that kind of
configuration
is not at all natural and so it would be
very natural to say
even before general relativity was
invented you could say well i think the
universe began a few billion years ago
right and that would have been a bold
move that boltzmann or someone else
could have made
but no one did even after einstein came
along
people like friedman really needed to
convince him that there probably was a
big bang at the beginning
okay um let me also talk about the fact
that the
entropy of the early universe was low so
um
there are by the way the entropy of the
early universe was low
but there are people even today modern
cosmologists who don't know that
and it's uh it's a little bit weird and
the reason they don't know it is because
if you take the box of gas
right that we were talking about before
and you open it up and you look at the
box
of gas which is in thermal equilibrium
so it's as high as entropy as it can be
it looks like a black body it is giving
off radiation according to the black
body radiation curve that we talked
about way long ago with planck and
quantum mechanics and all that okay
so the universe the early universe was a
black body
it gives off the cosmic microwave
background radiation that we can observe
in our telescopes today
and a box of gas in its maximum entropy
state looks like a black body it's the
same
distribution inside so therefore people
say
aha the early universe was high entropy
just like a box of gas that is a black
body
that is thermally distributed but that's
completely false
and the reason why it's false is because
inside the box of gas
gravity is not important and i don't
mean the gravity of the earth pulling
the gas down i mean the mutual gravity
of the particles inside the box right
gravity is a very very weak force and
the particles are going to bump into
each other
but their gravitational interactions are
completely negligible
in that regime when you can ignore the
gravity between the particles
it is certainly true that a smooth
distribution of gas at more or less the
same temperature
is as high in entropy as you can get but
that was
not what the early universe was like the
early universe was incredibly densely
packed with stuff
the gravitational pull between different
parts of the universe was really really
important
and when you turn on gravity there's
another way to get much much higher
entropy
than with a thermal distribution of gas
namely just make a black hole
okay so the entropy of
the universe of let's say the entropy of
gas in the universe
so what i mean by this is we have an
observable amount of universe that we
can see today
let's fix that volume of co-moving space
so let that volume
shrink into the past so we're keeping
track of the same stuff
as the universe expands or contracts so
the same number of particles right i
mean there's some particles that leave
the volume but an equal number come in
so roughly speaking an equal number of
particles
in the co-moving universe so if we draw
it like this
time going up
the universe used to be smaller this is
a co-moving patch with a certain number
of particles
and we actually know roughly speaking
how many particles there are in our
observable universe
and we can calculate their entropy and
the answer is around 10 to the 88th
okay a big number but still it's not the
biggest possible number
uh the entropy of a single
10 to the sixth solar mass black hole
so we talked in the q a video
for gravity about black hole
thermodynamics stephen hawking jacob
beckenstein
and others showed that black holes have
entropy you can even calculate them
we gave the formula for it proportional
to the area therefore
roughly proportional to the mass squared
of the black hole
uh the centers of big galaxies like the
milky way have black holes that are
millions of times the mass of the sun
a single black hole that has the mass of
a million times the mass of the sun has
an entropy of around 10 to the 90th
okay the black hole the center of our
milky way galaxy is something like 4
million times the mass of the sun
so it's easy to make a black hole with
way more entropy than the observable
universe had
and in fact we think that the maximum
entropy that you could make from all the
stuff in the observable universe
is around 10 to 123.
so 10 to the 88th is nothing it's
incredibly tiny compared to what the
early universe could have had as an
entropy
which is very compatible with the past
hypothesis that the universe began in a
low entropy state and indeed the history
of the universe
since the big bang is one where the
uh radiation cools but matter becomes
lumpier
right matter pulls itself together under
the force of gravity
once gravity is important a smooth
distribution is not the highest entropy
distribution footnote there eventually
once the universe gets dilute enough it
will go back
to a point where the highest entropy
state is smooth once again and again
that's what we expect to have happen the
black holes
will eat up all the mass in the universe
but then they will gradually evaporate
and we'll be left with nothing but a
thin group of particles and that's the
true
highest entropy state so once you have
gravity in the game
the behavior of entropy is weird when
you're very densely packed and gravity
is important
high entropy means lumpy
if gravity is not important high entropy
means smooth
if gravity is important but things have
diluted away again then high entropy
means
smooth again so it's a little weird but
that's okay we're uh
we figured it out this is stuff we
actually do understand
what we don't understand is why the
early universe had a low entropy state
we have we have no agreed upon theory
let's put it that way and i say that
very very carefully because
most working cosmologists don't even try
they don't even try to come up with a
theory it dynamically explains why the
early universe had low entropy
i've tried i wrote a paper in 2004 with
jennifer chen where we proposed a
complicated model with baby universes
and quantum nucleation of space-time
that would dynamically explain why the
whole universe had a low entropy
but there's not not that our model is
that great but we have almost no
competition
people are just not trying and i think
that more people should try i think
i'm not saying that i mean our model has
good aspects
it might point the way toward the right
model but i think there's probably still
some work to be done before we
understand that
but anyway that's speculative that's not
what we're here to talk about
um at the biggest ideas series we're
here to talk about the ideas that we
think
are right okay so that was low schmidt's
reversibility objection
then there is another very closely
related objection called
zermelo's objection now zermelo
turns out he became a famous guy at the
time circa you know 1895
he was i think a postdoc or a graduate
student working with max plunk
so he started out well he became very
famous as a mathematician
set theories or melo funkel set theory
is something that you will read about if
you become a pure mathematician
so he was more a mathematician than a
physicist and you know he read about
boltzmann's work and so forth but he
also read about
uh this theorem by henry poncaret
the french physicist and mathematician
about
recurrence in physical systems so ponca
ray
is interested in things like the solar
system so imagine that you just have the
solar system you don't don't let the
planets interact with each other okay
think of all the planets
just circling around the sun and they
all look the whole
arrangement of planets looks different
at every moment of time right
but what poncare proved is that if you
wait long enough any given
configuration of planets around the sun
will appear again you know the plants
will all move at different rates it
takes different amount of time for the
plants to move around the sun but if you
wait long enough
any arrangement that they started in
they'll get back to okay so that's
called the poincare recurrence theorem
and it led zermelo to come up with what
is called the recurrence objection
so zermelo being embedded in this german
tradition at the time uh also felt that
the second law of thermodynamics
should be a law so he had a very simple
uh objection
so poncare
i don't know which way the accent goes
from punk ray's name
uh says that a closed
bounded so these mean two different
things closed means no interactions from
the outside world
bounded mean there's only a finite
number of things that the system can do
so in the solar system
the only finite number of places each
planet can be
classical system
returns
to any configuration so there might be
configurations you never reach but if
you reach a configuration at one time
you will come back to it again and again
infinitely often if you live in
eternal universe if you wait it might
take a very long time in fact typically
it does the poincare recurrence time is
very long
but it will eventually happen so zermelo
says
um z says
a function he's a mathematician remember
he's thinking of entropy as a function
of time
can't both
be recurrent
coming back to the same value that it
had in the past so what he's saying is
if the universe is a closed system and
has a certain entropy its
micro state should come back to the same
configuration again and again and again
so the entropy
can maybe goes up but it's got to go
down again right to get back to where it
started
so that's recurrent and it can't both be
recurrent and
monotonic monotonic means
changing in the same direction for all
time but the second law
dsdt greater than or equal to zero says
that entropy should be monotonic
ponca ray's theorem says that entropy
should be recurrent but that you can't
have both
so zermelo's conclusion from this
was that the the whole idea of boltzmann
and maxwell that gases can be thought of
as
microscopic systems of particles obeying
newton's laws
is just wrong right he thought that the
second law was a law
that he he didn't think that physical
systems really did recur
he thought that they just had entropy
that increased okay and he said that
boltzmann did not succeed in explaining
why not
so boltzmann at this point you know in
the 1890s
boltzmann was uh kind of a big deal
he was a famous guy and he responded uh
pretty snootly actually to
zermelo's objection he said something
like well you know i suppose i should be
happy that people in germany pay
attention to my ideas at all
but it's sad to see they completely fail
to understand them so
and then he goes on and explaining why
the
recurrence objection isn't valid but you
know he's not
very convincing about it to be honest
now there's a simple way out
just say the universe is not bounded
right the universe is not
a finite sized system it can just expand
and change forever that's what
uh jennifer chen and i took advantage of
and our solution to this um so i mean
the
big universe out there right so maybe
that is the perfectly obvious thing to
think
but you know boltzmann tried to be a
little bit more clever
so boltzmann says well
maybe it is recurrent right maybe that's
the actual
behavior of entropy over time but i'm
going to invent a new principle he
didn't call it this but we would now
call it
the anthropic principle
so boltzmann appreciated as he should
because he was boltzmann
that in order for life to exist
you need entropy to increa be increasing
okay
um everything that we do in our lives
that is embedded in the arrow of time
relies on the fact that entropy is
increasing we need to take in low
entropy
food and eat it and then expel heat and
waste into the environment in order to
stay alive
so boltzmann said look imagine you have
a really really big universe okay
uh that is infinitely big both in space
and in time
and there's a uniform distribution of
matter on average
again we didn't know about general
relativity he didn't know the universe
should expand or contract etc so he had
fixed newtonian space-time
full of matter okay he also didn't know
about gravity and instabilities i mean
he knew about
newtonian gravity but he didn't realize
that there should be instabilities in
that kind of situation he imagined
just imagine it's like a box of gas but
really really big
and then what happens then in that box
of gas he says look if you plot
in some region of space the entropy
as a function of time if it's an eternal
universe then usually there'll be some
maximum entropy
okay and usually that's where the
universe will live
it will be close to its equilibrium
state almost all the time
but since i'm boltzmann i know there
will be fluctuations downward in entropy
so the real plot won't just be a
straight line it will be usually up
there but there'll be little deviations
and sometimes there'll be a big
deviation if you wait long enough
right so this
should be and this can be recurrent
right there can be another big deviation
later so he says this is completely
compatible
with recurrence and then he says
well in the regions where entropy is
just high and you're in equilibrium life
cannot exist
so by the anthropic principle which
again he didn't call it that but he says
i'm not going to ever find myself in
that region of the universe
whereas when the entropy goes down and
then springs back up
that's when stars and planets in life
can exist
so maybe we live here
right maybe that's where we find
ourselves in the aftermath
of an occasional unlikely random
fluctuation
downward in entropy and then back up
that was one of the ideas
that he had he also had this past
hypothesis idea but this is one of the
ideas he put forward he was a little
embarrassed to put it forward he
actually attributed to his old
assistant dr schutz but he later sort of
stopped giving anyone else credit for it
when he mentioned it later um
it doesn't work this idea of boltzmann's
is just bad and and you know why
probably boltzmann as far as i know
never pinpointed the reason why it was
arthur eddington
circa 1915 who really understood why
this couldn't possibly work
and the answer is there's a big problem
with this
and the answer is boltzmann brains
what we now call boltzmann brains
neither boltzmann or eddington ever
called them that
uh i think that coin the term was coined
by andy albrecht and lorenzo sorbo
in the 2000s right fairly recently um so
the problem is
sure if you really do have this infinite
universe that lasts forever and there's
fluctuations downward and back
up you will get occasional fluctuations
that create a galaxy or even a whole
universe
but far more often you'll get tiny
fluctuations
and maybe they will just make a little
brain
i don't know how to draw a brain okay
in other words there will be an
enormously larger number of small
fluctuations than big ones
and the fluctuation you need to make a
person or a planet
is enormously more rare than the
fluctuation you need just to make a
single brain that lives long enough to
go look around and go huh thermal
equilibrium and then it dies
technically the probability of a
fluctuation downward
in entropy is proportional to e to the
minus
the fluctuation size so large
fluctuations are exponentially more rare
which says that it's just another way of
saying that if you want to fluctuate
into a person if you think about it it's
a random fluctuation you sort of need to
separately have a fluctuation that makes
a brain
and a fluctuation that makes the body of
the brain and if you want not just a
person but a planet and a solar system
you need separate independent
fluctuations for all of those things
and it's just way easier to get a
fluctuation into one of those things
than do all of them
at the same time so eddington says with
overwhelming probability
observers in this multiverse of
boltzmann's randomly fluctuating
multiverse
would find themselves to be single
observers lonely and without anything
else anywhere around
they would not find themselves like we
do to be thermodynamically sensible
creatures living in the aftermath of a
low entropy big bang
and this this objection is correct you
know i've written a paper explaining
that
there's a little bit of philosophy to be
done here and explaining exactly why
the argument works because you know we
look around as we say well we're not a
boltzmann brain so can i just say
even if most of the observers are
boltzmann brains i'm not one of them
therefore it doesn't bother me
uh you can't say that but it's it's a
complicated reason why so i'm not going
to go into it but
the conclusion is still the same okay
the conclusion is we cannot live in a
randomly
fluctuating universe that lasts
eternally
like this uh better solutions
than the randomly fluctuating one
are that either the universe is
finite so
finite in time in particular so if the
entropy of the universe
well no that not the entropy that's
called the size of the universe
as a function of time does this okay
if there's a big bang and a big crunch
in the in the future
then there's not enough time for all
these recurrences to happen and
everything makes perfect sense
the problem with that is that in 1998 we
discovered the universe is
accelerating not decelerating so it
doesn't look like the universe is gonna
crunch in a finite time
the other possibility is that uh the
universe is not bounded
so finite in time
is not bounded in entropy
so what we mean by this is the the thing
that did all the work here
in the fluctuating scenarios that there
was a maximum amount of entropy
that you could have and therefore you
would tend to stay there
most of the time but what if
the plot of entropy
versus time has the feature there's no
maximum entropy state
that you can be in then the plot can
look like this
it can increase both to the past and the
future and so there will be people
living on this side
who say oh this was the past
toward that region there'll be also
people living over here
who say that's the past so in the far
past and far future of the universe
everything is completely symmetric
it's equivalent to each other
statistically anyway and that's the kind
of thing that i suggested in 2004 with
jennifer chen
we don't know which of these is true
it's still very possible the universe
being finite in time is a good solution
to this problem
but people again don't think about it
enough this is a huge
problem for modern cosmology that people
are not spending nearly enough time
thinking about
that's that's my two cents anyway okay
there you go that's the uh reason why we
have an arrow of time in the universe
and that's what the arrow of time is
uh at least the thermodynamic arrow time
as we call it the entropy increasing
error of time
i want to claim though much more i want
to claim that all of the arrows of time
are due to the thermodynamic arrow of
time
and this is again a contentious claim uh
but it's correct
you should leave me on this one not
everyone believes me but they will
sometime the claim is that the second
law
underlies
all of the arrows of time
what i mean by all the arrows are things
like
the biological arrow we get older right
we get a little creakier as time goes on
um there's a macrobiological arrow
evolution happens toward the future
there's a psychological arrow of time
you remember the past
but not the future there's a causal
arrow of time when i
do something now it can affect the
future but it cannot affect the past
there's an electromagnetic arrow of time
you turn a light bulb
light goes away from the light bulb but
light never focuses in on the light bulb
when you turn it on okay
so the claim is that all of these
imbalances
asymmetries between past and future are
ultimately because of the second law of
thermodynamics
and like i said this is contentious and
i'm not going to completely explain it
but i will give you the basic reason why
this is true and the reason why is
because
of the past hypothesis if you believe in
this
statistical microscopic view that
boltzmann and maxwell and their friends
put forward the past hypothesis of low
entropy at some time a few billion years
ago 14 billion years ago
is the only thing that breaks the
symmetry between past and future and
therefore it had
better explain all of the arrows of time
and the rough way that works if you
think about
time going upward and this is not
space that i'm plotting here but it's
you know the state of the world
so it's phase space roughly speaking
the state of all possible ways the world
can be
and the claim is the idea is that we
have some information
about the current state of the world uh
we have some directly we have some by
inference
but we have some state about what you
might call some information about what
you might call our current macro state
okay so this represents our current
macro state and
as as low schmidt would have told us
correctly
if all you know is our current macro
state and the microscopic laws of
physics
there are trajectories toward the future
from our current macro state
and there are trajectories from the past
into our current macro state
and they are precisely equal in number
okay there's no difference in the number
of ways the microstate
can evolve into the future versus the
number of ways it could have come from
in the past because the underlying laws
are reversible
information is conserved in this
evolution okay
so there's no difference here between
past and future but
a difference appears when we say i have
a past boundary condition from the past
hypothesis
that the past was in low entropy
so it is a feature of
most of all these other trajectories
here
i give them another color
these have higher entropy
than the current macro state and that's
exactly because of you know
this picture we drew way up here if you
start anywhere
that is not maximum entropy most of the
trajectories coming in
and most of the trajectories going out
are both higher entropy places that you
come from and go to
so that's true in the future but it's
also true in the past
so there's many ways for entropy to
increase toward the future there are
many ways
for entropy to have been larger and to
get us into our current macro state
the symmetry is broken by the idea
there's a past hypothesis that says that
early universe had low entropy and that
means
that given our current macro state and
the past hypothesis you can figure out
things about the trajectory that got
us there and those things are called
memories
or records of the past if you're on a
beach and you see a footprint
you say to yourself well i bet there was
a foot
i bet that someone walked on the beach
and left an impression
of course you're correct about that but
it doesn't follow
simply from the fundamental laws of
physics in the space of all possible
ways for that footprint to get there
most of them have the footprint randomly
fluctuating into existence
okay the reason why in your brain you're
convinced
that the footprint is evidence for a
previous foot being there
is because secretly you're
conditionalizing your probabilities on
the past being low entropy given that
the past was much much lower entropy
then the easiest way to get footprints
on the beach is to have a foot
stand on them not to wait around a
gajillion years for a random fluctuation
so that's true for all the ways in which
we remember things and by memory i don't
necessarily
just mean a physical memory in our brain
i mean any kind of record a history book
a photograph a fossil
footprint any of those things they all
make sense because we're assuming a low
entropy past
same thing is true for why we can cause
things toward the future but not the
past the rough idea is that
the past seems fixed and settled
because of the low entropy past
hypothesis the future seems more
up for grabs and affectable because
there's no future hypothesis the entropy
just grows as far
as we know and that's why you know we
can talk about
free will in a sensible way because we
can't talk about free will toward the
past
but we can talk about it toward the
future because you know if you were
laplace's demon there'd be no free will
right you would just have a microscopic
world and it would obey the laws of
physics and the past and future would be
equal
but in the real world we don't have
access to all that microscopic
information we can say things about the
past and future but there's an imbalance
about what we can say
so we act as if in the macroscopic world
we are able to influence
what happens that's the sensible way to
talk about big human scale things that's
why it makes sense to talk about choices
and responsibility and blame and all
that stuff that we normally like to talk
about with human beings
okay that was one important aspect of uh
the past hypothesis and the increase in
entropy
here's another one life
i talked about the fact that boltzmann
recognized that uh you need
an increase in entropy for living beings
to exist let me just mention that
one more time with a little bit more
specificity you know here we are
on earth here's earth and we have living
creatures so here's a person
on earth here is you know plant flower
and to some extent
as you will learn i keep advertising my
podcast here but i just released a
podcast
a couple weeks ago about the definition
of life
and one of the parts of the definition
of life is homeostasis you can
maintain your integrity as a
creature as a physical object and
the fact that seems like a very natural
thing you know we all know in the back
of our minds we need to breathe
we need to drink we need to eat in order
for that to happen
but it's really possible because we are
embedded in a very low entropy
out of equilibrium environment in
particular
you know we get light from the sun so
here's the sun okay
radiating it's light to us and if you
ask someone well what good is the sun
to us here on earth they might say well
the sun gives us energy
and we use energy to do things and
that's
true in a sense but it's not the
complete story it's not even the most
important part of the story because the
truth is
the earth radiates out into space almost
exactly the same amount of energy as it
gets from the sun
historically exactly the same amount of
energy but these days we have global
climate change which is warming up the
earth a little bit we're reading
away a little bit less of the energy
than we get from the sun but roughly
speaking the same amount of energy
so the point is not that we get energy
because we give the same amount of
energy back
the point is that we get energy in a low
entropy
form we get energy in a concentrated
form that is very useful to us
so for every single photon of visible
light
that we get from the sun we radiate out
i'm not going to be able to draw all of
them well let me maybe do 5
6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15
16 17 18 19 20 photons
of infrared light
this is not something you can calculate
from first principles this is a true
fact about the earth and its atmosphere
we can radiate away infrared light we
absorb visible light
so that means that we take a certain
amount of energy from the sun
you know infrared light per photon has
less energy
what we're saying here is that on
average for every one photon we get from
the sun
we radiate back 20 photons with 1 20th
of the energy
each but the number of photons is
proportional to the entropy
the energy of the photon has nothing to
do with it so we've
increased the entropy of that energy we
get from the sun by a factor of 20.
we've drawn down the orderliness of the
universe
made it more disorderly and in the
process
we stay alive so there's photosynthesis
in the plants
photosynthesis takes that energy from
the sun
it locks it up into a sugar or something
like that
we animals eat the sugar our bodies use
it to make atp
sends the atp molecules all throughout
our system with their little batteries
and they release their energy
to you know maintain ourselves move our
muscles uh make our brain work
all that stuff i mean it's it's amazing
to think about like you know how much
science has figured out
what's really going on here and the role
of entropy in the arrow of time in the
whole thing
it's all because we are very far from
equilibrium if if the whole
sky or the temperature of the sun
we'd get a lot more energy than we do
now right but it wouldn't be very
useful we here on earth would quickly
come to the temperature of the sun to
thermal equilibrium and then we would
all die
but also if the sun were if the sky were
completely dark
if the sun were not there then we here
on earth would quickly
come to the temperature of the night sky
equilibrate and
quickly die we stay out of equilibrium
we can be living creatures because we
get low entropy energy
use it up and then expel it back in a
much higher entropy form
again lots of science to be done here
that we don't yet know the answer to so
this is uh
ongoing research that we're trying to
understand okay
i'm going to keep talking because this
is my favorite topic entropy there's a
million things to say
it's worth many many lectures you can
buy the book if you want to hear more
but i'm going to give you some of the
highlights um because i got to get to
information right
i promised you entropy information so
let's get there
let's talk about maxwell's demon so this
takes us back
to the 1870s um james clark maxwell
was trying to understand this idea you
know that they could understand
entropy as a formula based on the
molecules
which seemed weird to a lot of people
and maxwell
thought he came up with what seemed like
a counter example
he came up with what thought he what he
thought seemed like a situation where
you could violate the second law of
thermodynamics without doing work again
you can always
put a glass a bottle of champagne in the
refrigerator and let its entropy go down
but guess what
the back of the refrigerator is
expelling a lot of heat
the overall entropy of the universe is
going up even if the entropy of that
bottle of champagne is going down
that's why you cannot cool your
apartment by turning on a refrigerator
and opening the door
because it will always be expelling more
heat at the back
than it is cooling in the front because
of the second law of thermodynamics okay
so but aside from that maxwell's saying
that without
increasing entropy anywhere he can come
up with a way to decrease entropy
in an isolated system so you all know
the situation probably
here is a box of gas and there is a
barrier
in between with a hole in the barrier
and there's a demon
standing on top my picture of a demon
looks exactly like a person
except that he has little horns and the
demon
has access to a little paddle
which he can raise up and down so he can
move the paddle in front of the hole
to either let particles through or
prevent them from going through and the
important thing is it's all frictionless
you know there's no air resistance or
anything like that
but the lifting the paddle up and down
does a net total of zero work
the demon is not adding to the energy of
the system nor is the demon taking away
energy of the system he's just changing
the boundary conditions of the box
in an apparently innocuous innocent
harmless way
and the idea is you know you have atoms
molecules flying around in here
and in thermal equilibrium both sides of
the box would have the same temperature
the same number of
slow-moving molecules and fast-moving
molecules
but maxwell's idea was that the daemon
could look
into the box without disturbing the
molecules he could see when a
high-energy
molecule was approaching his little
paddle and if so he would let it through
from one side to the other and the other
direction he would let the low energy
molecules through and by doing that
he would create hot gas on one side of
the box and cool gas on the other
which is a lower entropy configuration
so maxwell's worry
is that the entropy of the universe is
spontaneously going down without being
created anywhere else
now everyone in the world thought ever
since maxwell came up with this that
clearly somehow the demon
is creating entropy and the the quest
was just to figure out
how exactly the actions of the demon are
creating entropy in the universe and it
took
decades and decades it wasn't really
until the 1980s
believe it or not that people really
settled on an answer which
most people accept now but still not
everyone accepts it
and it comes from rolf landauer
and charlie bennett
and their essential insight is that
the relationship between information and
entropy
so the demon needs to be able to know
whether a certain molecule is high
energy high
velocity high energy or low energy right
so the demon needs to record that
information
somehow there needs to be an information
recording device that the demon has
access to
and that information recording device
you know they make an argument that it
essentially has to be finite sized
otherwise you're sort of giving the
demon an infinite resource to
play with and the demon if it has a
finite size recording device
the demon must record info
and eventually if the whole thing goes
on for a long time
erase that information
erase it okay it is that process of
erasing
information in his record-keeping device
in his little notebook
that's what increases the entropy of the
universe because one way
that you should keep in the back of your
mind the increase of entropy
has a close relationship with
irreversibility remember when we said
that
the gibbs entropy formula would just
stay constant
if you had perfect laws of physics and
no nose looking inside the box and that
you were not embedded in a heat bath or
anything like that okay
information is conserved everything is
reversible
once things are not reversible that's
when entropy begins to be
increasing and the act of erasing
something in your notebook
is not reversible the whole point of
erasing is you don't know what it was
anymore so you've erased a zero or a one
and afterward you no longer know whether
it was a zero or a one so you cannot
reverse that
and they argue that this creates entropy
in fact erasing one bit uh
of information creates an entropy delta
s
of k log two the natural logarithm of
the number two so that
an exact calculable amount of entropy
that you create in the universe by
erasing a single
bit of information and doing it requires
energy
as a this requires energy
e equals k t log2
where t is the temperature of the
surroundings that you're in
so and this these ideas are known as
landauer's principle
ah that was terrible and worse
principle and i'm not doing justice to
the subtleties here because i just want
to get the basic idea
on your plate that we can begin to see
the relationship between
entropy and information basically the
demon needs to have
information and losing that information
counts as increasing the entropy of the
universe
in a way that relates directly to things
like temperature and energy
this is this is the idea that is trotted
out when people want to say
information is physical okay knowing
things
can be used to do work can be used to
manipulate the world and in fact these
days
people are building tiny little maxwell
demons uh it's not that maxwell's demon
is impossible it's just that you need to
have some way for it to have information
and eventually that information will be
erased thus increasing the entropy of
the universe
so the point is that you can build a
little machine
that can actually using the information
it has about its environment
seem to do work it can convert
information
into work by work we mean physical
energy
that you move from one place to another
like you can move a piston
okay or uh arguably there's a connection
here with what molecules do
inside your body we talked about the atp
other things going on inside your body
seam and again this is cutting edge
stuff that we don't completely
understand
but there seems to be a relationship
between the use of information
and the growth of entropy and complexity
in your body
there's another very promising research
area for the youngsters to go into if
you're interested in this stuff
but i just like it because it you know
it's a fun
way that we start going from physical
stuff molecules and things moving around
to what seems like a slightly more
abstract realm of
information and knowledge so let's go
down that rabbit hole a little bit
further
more into the direction of information
because you've all heard
of claude shannon
claude shannon was the pioneer of
information theory he worked at bell
labs
and he was really interested in again
down to earth stuff like
this is this whole field he was
interested in communications
sending signals along wires
this whole field of statistical
mechanics and thermodynamics and entropy
has a lot of connections with tangible
real world stuff
carnot saji carnot who first formulated
a version of the second law of
thermodynamics
his motivation was not to understand
fundamental physics his motivation was
to build a better steam engine
right it was early 1800s he was french
he was upset that the french were not
doing
as well at building steam engines as the
british were and so he tried to do
better
and he prove that you could never do a
perfect thing you could never build a
perfect steam engine
every steam engine has to dissipate and
be irreversible
in some way so likewise shannon
really literally was interested in the
most efficient way to send
signals over wires knowing that there
would be errors right
there's going to be mistakes you never
get the signal and interpret it
completely so you have to be clever you
have to think about how
best most safety most efficiently most
reliably
to send your signal over you know a
transatlantic cable or something like
that
so here is his setup and it's going to
sound completely different than what
we've been talking about so far
but then we'll see how it joins back up
the setup is you want to send
symbols
and by symbols you might mean letters in
an alphabet or you might mean words or
if you're more mathy you might mean just
zeros and ones uh morse code or
something like that
and you want to send them over a channel
so a channel it could be a wire but
again what we're doing here is taking
the tangible problem
i want to send a telegraph signal over
wire and turning into a formal
question so i'm sending something called
symbols over something called the
channel right and these these all have
mathematical
realizations and if i receive a whole
bunch of symbols
i receive many messages over time um if
you
like if you if you read a book if you
read an english language
text you will notice that not all words
appear with the same frequency there are
common words and uncommon words
there are common letters and uncommon
letters letters like e
and s appear a lot letters like q and x
appear less frequently okay so you can
just count the frequency you can be
kind of frequentist about it and say
well what is the probability
of the next symbol that i'm going to
receive being a certain symbol versus
something else some are more probable
than others
so let p of x be the probability
of receiving simple x
i don't mean the letter x i mean
whatever symbol
x stands for here then what shannon says
is some signals
some messages some communications that
you get
convey more information than others
by virtue of the fact that they are more
surprising
than others okay and so he uh relates
the
information content
to what we sometimes call the surprisal
i call it that because i think it's a
very cool word
and the formula is not that hard
the information content associated with
receiving symbol x
is just the logarithm of one over
p of x okay so the more probable
the lower the information content
remember the logarithm has this shape
but it goes up as the number that it's a
logarithm of goes up
and the logarithm of one over p of x let
me tell you another fact about
logarithms if you don't know
uh the logarithm of a
to the power b equals b times the
logarithm of a
it's just a math fact about logarithms
you can you can check for yourself
so p of x one over p of x is p to the
minus one
so this is just minus the logarithm
of p of x oops
and this is called the surprisal okay
the more
the lower the probability of a message
of a symbol reaching you
the more information it contains so the
way to think about it is you know
someone says oh the sun rose in the east
this morning
okay you're not that surprised like you
go okay
good i hope what else would it have done
but if someone says the sun rose in the
west this morning
if they were a reliable witness you'd be
extremely surprised
and that would convey a lot more
information to you so
in some naive way the statement the sun
rose in the east
and the state of the sun rose in the
west they both convey one bit of
information did the sun rise in one
direction or the other direction right
but the bits are not created equal this
is shannon's great insight the bits
depend on the context in which you
expect
to receive certain bits of information
with certain probabilities
if every morning you get a report the
sunrise in the east or the west
the probability of it being in the east
is really really high you are not
surprised
when you get that not much information
is
conveyed okay so
shannon then goes on to say all right in
different kinds of
alphabets different kinds of sets of
symbols different kinds of languages
we might expect on average to be
surprised and get information
frequently or infrequently okay so
he defines the average
surprise surprisal
which is just the sum over all possible
symbols that you might receive of the
probability of getting that symbol
p sub x let me write sorry to be
consistent
what i've been writing p of x times the
surprisal the information content
i of x right so this is a formula
that says you know some symbols are
going to happen a lot
let's calculate the surprisal there and
some symbols are going to happen rarely
let's calculate the surprisal there and
get the average
okay so the average weighted by the
likelihood of actually getting those
symbols
um so guess what
i is minus log p okay so we define this
to be h of the
set of symbols x and it is minus the sum
over x
of the probability of x times the log of
the probability of x
so shannon derived this formula he
didn't even know about statistical
mechanics he didn't know about boltzmann
and gibbs he didn't know that there's
already a formula exactly like this this
is exactly
what we called before gibbs's formula
for the entropy
okay so basically the way to think about
what shannon has
done is to say look if i have different
kinds of
alphabets different kinds of sets of
symbols different kinds of messages i
might receive
x are the different symbols i receive
and
there's the different probability for
getting different messages x
if the probability function looks like
this
then basically what you're saying is
almost all the time
you're getting this symbol so even
though you're getting a symbol it's not
telling you very much you're not
conveying that much information
because it's the same symbol you're
getting all the time so this is a
low information
alphabet
it is a it is exactly equivalent to a
low entropy configuration
in phase space whereas something like
this
now you're saying well sometimes you get
the symbol sometimes you get that symbol
every single time you get a symbol
you're learning something
because there's no one kind of symbol
that is overwhelmingly likely
so this kind of symbol set is high
information
so if you care about sending signals
over wires you want to get a high
entropy
high information content encoding for
your messages so that you actually
convey
information all the time now you might
wonder you might say well okay
sure if i have this peaked distribution
most of the time i'm getting a low
information content message
but on the other hand when i do get an
unlikely low probability message doesn't
it convey so much information that it
wins out
well the answer is no it does not win
out the fact that the information is
lower
is is swamped by the fact that the
probability is even lower and you can
sort of feel that
here or here because remember the
logarithm grows
slowly so the logarithm is going to lose
the battle
against the actual probability so what
counts for whether or not your alphabet
is high information conveying or low
information conveying
is the probability of the most probable
symbols that's what the one that's what
really matters
so this is now called the shannon
entropy
or the expected information content and
there's a story
which many of you probably have heard
that shannon was talking to john von
neumann of all people
and said i have this new quantity that i
want to define what should i call it
and and uh von neumann says purportedly
says i'm not sure if it's true he said
well you should call it the entropy for
two reasons
number one is because there's already a
formula that looks like that which is
called the entropy
and the other is nobody knows what
entropy means so in conversation you can
always be sure to win because no one
knows what you're talking about
and yeah it's a little bit unfair but
there's a there's a
sense of truth to that now what i want
to mention about this
is that this is all about information
this is clearly about information this
is not you know these x's
are not points in phase space they're
symbols in an alphabet
but there's a little bit of a mismatch
between how a communication
theorist would talk about information or
care about information
versus how a physicist would okay so
shannon is saying that low entropy
corresponds to low information high
entropy corresponds to high information
that's the opposite of what we said
before right when we talked about the
knowledge that we have the information
we have about a system
given a certain probability distribution
if the probability distribution is very
peaked
then we know a lot about the system we
know more or less what microstate it's
in whereas if the probability
distribution is all spread out we don't
know anything
about the system it could be anything so
to a physicist
physicists tend to associate high
entropy
with low information content because
they're thinking of the entropy of
a distribution on phase space and the
information that they have in mind is
where are you in phase space
but a communication theorist like
shannon has a completely different
notion this is
mathematically formally the same but
what they mean by high information
content
is how much information is conveyed by
any one element of that alphabet and if
the probabilities are all spread out
equally
a lot of information is being conveyed
by getting any one symbol in that
alphabet in other words by sort of
measuring the microstate of the system
once by one by one
you learn more in a high entropy
configuration than in the low entropy
configuration
so i just want to let you know that
because when
everyone agrees there's a close
relationship between entropy and
information but different people from
different subfields think the
relationship goes in opposite ways
so just keep your wits about you they're
both perfectly sensible ways of thinking
but they're different ways of thinking
depending on what you're thinking about
okay final thing good one more thing
which is because this is the biggest
ideas in the universe
we would be remiss if we did not talk
about quantum mechanics
because we love quantum mechanics
and there is a separate notion i told
you i was going to need
four definitions of entropy so i gave
you the boltzmann definition with coarse
graining
gave you the gibbs definition the sum of
p
log p uh for distribution function for
for a probability distribution in phase
space i gave you shannon's definition
which looks formally exactly the same
as gibbs is but it means something
different
and now i'm going to give you a fourth
definition in the context of
quantum mechanics i'm going to i'm going
to tell you there is a definition
without writing down the formula because
it requires extra notation to get there
but this comes from jon von neumann von
neumann uh
the great hungarian mathematical
physicist came up with a way
to understand that quantum mechanics
leads to
a kind of entropy that is new
or at least it's an origin of entropy
over and above what you used to have so
remember if you think about the gibbs
entropy
you have some probability distribution
the entropy is really telling you how
much you don't know
about the microstate right so what van
loyman points out is that because of
entanglement
you can have a situation where you know
everything there is to know
about the state of a composite system
but there's a sense in which you don't
know the states of the subsystems that
are entangled
because there is no such thing as the as
the state of the subsystem so
remember uh so this is entanglement
entropy
or sometimes just called von neumann
entropy
and we go back to alice and bob and
they're
entangled spins
so imagine that alice and bob's spins
have a wave function
psi that is one over the square root of
two
both spins up so there's alice's spin up
bob's spin is up
plus one over square root of two both
spins are down
for alice and for bob and you remember
the story
right like if alice measures her spin we
instantly know what bobspin is but bob
doesn't know that so the bob is still a
50 50 chance
etc etc this is a 50 50 chance of both
spins being up or both spins being down
were you to observe either one of them
so here's the situation i told you the
wave function remember when if you go
back to our discussion of the
uncertainty principle
the point is that there's no more
information to give you
about the physical set up of the system
you know if you're a hidden variables
person maybe there's more information
but here in
wave function land this is the entire
quantum state
of the system we're not leaving anything
out so you might say in some sense this
is a situation
with zero entropy you know the
microstate this is the microstate
of the system and that's true that is a
perfectly valid way of
of calculating the entropy for this
system but you might also want to say
well
what is the entropy of alice's spin
right and what we what i tried to teach
you
to say um back when we talked about
entanglement is
there is no wave function for alice's
spin because alice's spin is entangled
with bobspin so alice's spin does not by
itself have a wave function
there are not separate wave functions
for the different pieces of the universe
there's one wave function for the wave
function of the universe and it's
entangled in this way okay
but what von neumann points out is that
observationally
when it comes to actually calculating
anything you might want to observe about
alice's spin
anything alice might want to observe
about her spin
okay we can ignore
bob's spin and replace alice's the
replace the wave function of the
composite system
with an uncertain wave function and
again this is this is this
little subtle so follow along here
you we talk about a wave function of a
spin being uncertain
to with respect to what spin you are
going to get
if you were to measure it but now we're
doing a different thing we're saying
we're uncertain
about the wave function that's a whole
other level of uncertainty and so we
call this
this is a pure state up here
and now we're going to consider mixed
states where we don't
even know what the wave function is and
so observationally
it's as if
alice's spin
is described
by a mixed quantum state
where the probability of alice's spin
being just spin up so literally
the probability that alice has a spin
with a wave function that is 100
spin up is 0.5
and the probability that alice has a
spin with a wave function
that is completely down is also 0.5
so it's like having the probability
distribution on phase space
right when we had a probability
distribution phase space we said well
there is some
point microscopic state of the system we
just don't know what it is so we have
some probability distribution
this is trickier because there is no
such thing
as the state of alice's spin the quantum
wave function of alice's spin it's
entangled with bobs
but for everything you might want to
possibly calculate about what you're
going to observe when you do things to
alice's spin
you would get the same answer if you
started in this mixed
state and you can even there's a formal
thing that fond neumann describes about
tracing over bob's spin to get this
mixed state
and these are described in the
literature by density matrices
we're not going to go into what that is
but as usual that's lingo if you want to
look it up density matrices or density
operators
so in some sense so what's going on here
here's the crucial thing
you have two systems a and b
and classically a has a state and b
has a state you might not know it and if
you don't know it if there's some
probability distribution there's an
entropy
quantum mechanically there's a state for
both a and b together
it's entangled and you know it exactly
maybe let's imagine you know it exactly
but it is as if the subsystem a
has a state and you don't know it
therefore
you can talk about the entropy of
subsystem a okay
so the density matrices are called rho
the greek letter rho is given to the
density matrix and the phenomena entropy
i told you i wasn't going to write it
down i'm writing it down
uh the volume and entropy of
rho is the trace
of rho log rho and the trace means the
sum of the diagonal elements
of a matrix so look minus there you go
it's the same formula trace is kind of
like the sum or the integral
and rho is kind of like the probability
distribution
um so i'm being less specific than i've
been in the past but
you see the same structure appearing
the difference the conceptual difference
here is that this is
still true even if you know the complete
state of the universe
so quantum mechanics forces some entropy
on you
if you are choosing to consider
subsystems of larger systems because
they can be entangled
let me give you an example of a
subsystem of a larger system
here's space and here's a region of
space
okay let's imagine this is just the
quantum field theory vacuum
so there's no particles or anything like
that
but as you know as we talked about even
though there's no particles there's
entanglement
between the region inside and the region
outside and therefore
you can calculate the density matrix of
this region if you call this region
s no s is terrible oh my goodness call
it r
if this is region r there's a density
matrix rho sub r
and that density matrix has an entropy
regions of space
of empty space in quantum field theory
have entropy
even if you know that the whole state is
in the vacuum
so in technically speaking the entropy
is infinite
because it's quantum field theory but
maybe you regularize it and there's a
cut off and make it a finite number so
that's the usual renormalization story
effective field theory story
we think that in some sense you can
think about black hole
entropy this way because you notice that
even though the entropy is infinite
it's not crazy that the entropy is
proportional to the
area of the region that you've drawn
because the number of entangled
degrees of freedom is proportional to
that area also
so mark schreinke and other people
pointed this out and made an argument
maybe we should think of black hole
entropy as entanglement entropy
between what's inside the event horizon
and what's outside
the answer seems to be kind of
black hole entropy turns out to be
harder than that but in a very real
sense it does seem to be entanglement
entropy
it certainly seems to be entanglementary
of something but not quite
of degrees of freedom in the quantum
field theory vacuum
anyway so this is yet another formula
for entropy another way that entropy
arises and this is sort of less optional
than the gibbs or the boltzmann entropy
there's nothing that came in here about
coarse graining
or ignorance or anything like that it's
a built-in feature of the universe so
it's almost like quantum mechanics is
saying
you have to deal with entropy whether
you like it or not that's a good lesson
for all of us to take to heart